"
FOUR DAYS TO GO INTO THE LIMITED
TERMS AND ITS SPIN, BABY, SPIN
FOR THE DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SETTING THE TONE
AND STRAIGHT UP LYING TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ABOUT THE LOUSY
STATE OF THE ECONOMY AND KITCHEN
TABLE ISSUES.
>> LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE
FACTS.
WHEN I TOOK OFFICE, THIS ECONOMY
WAS IN RUINS.
THE ECONOMY IS OUT.
PRICE INFLATION IS DOWN.
REAL INCOMES ARE UP.
GAS PRICES ARE DOWN AND THE NEED
TO COME DOWN FURTHER.
EXPORTS ARE ALSO UP WHICH MEANS
A SIMPLE THING, WE ARE MAKING A
LOT OF MONEY IN AMERICA BECAUSE
OF THAT.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU THINK
THAT'S CRAZY?
BIDEN'S FRIENDS IN THE MEDIA ARE
TAKING THINGS TO THE NEXT LEVEL
BY CLAIMING REPUBLICANS MADE UP
THE TERM INFLATION TO HELP THEM
WIN.
>> THE ONLY PEOPLE I EVER HEAR
USE THE WORD INFLATION ARE
JOURNALISTS AND ECONOMISTS.
RIGHT?
THAT'S NOT PART OF THE NORMAL
LEXICON OF THE WAY PEOPLE TALK.
IT'S INTERESTING THE REPUBLICANS
ARE DOING SOMETHING THEY DON'T
NORMALLY DO, RIGHT, NOT USE THE
COMMON TONGUE.
NOT USING COMMON ENGLISH IN
THEIR CAMPAIGNS.
WHAT THEY'VE DONE IS THEY HAVE
TAUGHT PEOPLE THE WORD
INFLATION.
MOST PEOPLE WOULD'VE NEVER USE
THAT WORD EVER IN THEIR LIVES
ARE USING IT NOW BECAUSE THEY'VE
BEEN TAUGHT.
>> Judge Jeanine: SO INFLATION
IS JUST REPUBLICAN CREATED
TALKING POINT.
WHAT ABOUT CRIME?
PEOPLE ARE BEING RANDOMLY
ATTACKED AND KILLED IN THE
STREETS, HILLARY CLINTON SAYS
IT'S JUST A VAST RIGHT-WING
CONSPIRACY.
>> I'VE SEEN --
I AM SURE YOU HAVE, MAYBE YOU
DON'T WATCH TELEVISION, BUT IF
YOU DID.
YOU WOULD SEE WHAT I SEE WHICH
ARE ADS ABOUT CRIME EVERY 30
SECONDS, RIGHT?
NO SOLUTIONS.
JUST A LOT OF REALLY FEARFUL,
SCARY PICTURES AND SCARY MUSIC.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT KEEPING
YOU SAFE.
THEY WANT TO KEEP YOU SCARED.
>> Judge Jeanine: AND AFTER A
POLL SHOWED WHITE SUBURBAN WOMEN
MOVING TO REPUBLICANS IN A
MASSIVE 27-POINT SWING.
LEAVE IT TO LIBERAL FILMMAKER
MICHAEL MOORE TO TELL US WHAT
WOMEN VOTERS REALLY WANT.
>> TO BELIEVE THAT WE ARE GOING
TO LOSE ON TUESDAY AND THAT THEY
ARE GOING TO TAKE OVER, YOU HAVE
TO ACCEPT CERTAIN ASSUMPTIONS.
FOR INSTANCE, YOU HAVE TO
BELIEVE WHAT THE POLLSTERS AND
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN TELLING US
SINCE THE ROE V. WADE DECISION.
WOMEN ARE VERY UPSET IN JUNE
WHEN THE DECISION CAME DOWN.
BUT NOW THEY HAVE KIND OF
COLLECTIVE THEMSELVES AND THEY
ARE NOT SO UPSET.
THEY ARE THINKING MORE ABOUT THE
PRICE OF A GALLON OF GAS OR WITH
A CAN OF CAMPBELL'S SOUP IS UP
$0.27.
IT'S SO CONDESCENDING.
DO YOU REALLY THINK THAT WOMEN
ARE JUST OVER IT?
OVER ROE?
>> Judge Jeanine: WHAT'S
INTERESTING ABOUT THAT AS HE
TALKS ABOUT CONDESCENDING.
I THINK HE'S CONDESCENDING AND
SEXIST TO PRESUME WHAT WOMEN
WANT IN THIS ELECTION.
AS IF THEY DON'T BUY GROCERIES,
THEY DON'T FILL UP THEIR CAR
WITH GAS.
WHAT'S WITH HIM?
>> Dana: IT'S NOT JUST HIM BUT
LIKE JOY REID TO SUGGEST PEOPLE
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT THE WORD
INFLATION.
WE ALL WENT TO SCHOOL.
WE UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS.
EVEN IF YOU'VE NEVER HEARD THE
WORD, YOU KNOW WHAT IT FEELS
LIKE BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THEY'VE
BEEN DEALING WITH FOR SEVERAL
MONTHS NOW AND THEY'RE LOOKING
AT EVEN WORSE GOING INTO 2023 SO
THEY KNOW THAT.
THAT'S WHY PEOPLE ARE LOOKING
FOR CHANGE.
IT'S NOT HARD TO UNDERSTAND.
YOU TAKE WHAT HE SAID ABOUT
WOMEN --
ARE THEY OVER ROE?
MAYBE THEY ARE NOT BUT THEY HAVE
ALSO UNDERSTOOD STATES ARE GOING
TO DEAL WITH IT AND YOU LIVE IN
THE STATE LIKE NEW YORK, NOTHING
CHANGES FOR YOU ON ABORTION.
THEN YOUR MAIN ISSUE WHICH IS
AFFORDABILITY, HOUSING, YOUR
ELECTRICITY BILLS UNDERGOING
OUTCOME OF THE SCHOOL FEES THAT
WENT UP, ALL THE GAS AND
GROCERIES THAT YOU HAVE TO DEAL
WITH.
MAYBE YOU'RE TAKING CARE OF
AGING PARENTS.
ALL OF THOSE COSTS ARE BEARING
DOWN.
WOMEN TAKE A LOT ON.
THEY ARE STRETCHED.
TAKING CARE OF THE KIDS AND
TAKING CARE OF ELDERLY PARENTS,
TRYING TO WORK.
SUPER CONDESCENDING.
IT REMINDS ME OF WHAT SONNY
HUSTON SAID YESTERDAY, ANY WOMAN
WHO'S GOING TO VOTE FOR
REPUBLICANS LIKE ROACH.
IT'S ALMOST INCOMPREHENSIBLE.
HE CAN IMAGINE.
YOU CAN'T IMAGINE.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHAT SONNY
HUSTON SAID WAS THAT WHITE
SUBURBAN WOMEN ARE ROACHES
HEADING TOWARD RAID.
IF I SAID BLACK SUBURBAN WOMEN
WERE ROACHES HEADING TOWARDS
ANYTHING, I WOULD BE FINED.
>> NICE KNOWING YOU.
DIDN'T TRUMP SAY BALTIMORE WAS
RAT INFESTED AND IT WAS A THREE
WEEK STORY.
FIRST OF ALL, WITH JOY, WE
DIDN'T TEACH ANYBODY ANYTHING.
CARTER TAUGHT US ABOUT
INFLATION.
JOE JUST REMINDED US.
THIS IS WHAT I CALL THE
REPUBLICAN POUNDS ATTACK.
YOU NOT REALLY SCARED OF CRIME.
REPUBLICANS ARE SCARING YOU.
OR YOU DIDN'T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT HIGH PRICES UNTIL
REPUBLICANS TAUGHT YOU ABOUT
HIGH PRICES.
JOHNNY GOES OUT TO MANHATTAN AND
TALKS TO NEW YORKERS WHO DON'T
WATCH FOX.
JOHNNY DOESN'T SCARE ANYBODY.
LOOK AT JOHNNY.
HE IS NOT THAT SCARY.
ALSO JOHNNY DOESN'T TEACH
ANYBODY ANYTHING EXCEPT MAYBE
WHO WON THE CIVIL WAR.
SO YOU GET A SITUATION WHERE
HILLARY IS SAYING THIS IS A VAST
RIGHT-WING CONSPIRACY.
HER HUSBAND SIGNED A BILL BY
JOE BIDEN TO REDUCE CRIME IN THE
90s, WAS ZADA SCARY RIGHT-WING
CONSPIRACY.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS ON THE
MEDIA.
MICHAEL MOORE.
I FOUND, JEANINE, AND MY 40 PLUS
YEARS, IT'S NOT A GOOD IDEA TO
TELL WOMEN WHAT THEY THINK.
I HAVE FOUND IT'S A BETTER IDEA
TO LISTEN TO WOMEN AND THEN
SUMMARIZE.
THERE'S TWO SCENARIOS.
THE POLLS ARE EITHER RIGHT OR
MICHAEL MOORE KNOWS MORE ABOUT
WHAT WOMEN WANT THAN WOMEN.
I'M GOING THAT'S THE CASE.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHAT'S
INTERESTING, YOU HAVE
HILLARY CLINTON DENYING --
SHE LIVES IN NEW YORK.
CRIME IS THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE IN
NEW YORK STATE, AND SHE SAYS
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO SCARE THEM
WHICH REMINDS ME OF JEN PSAKI.
I WILL NEVER FORGET, SHE'S
LOOKING UP THE TV AND SAYING I'M
WATCHING FOX.
WHY IS JEANINE PIRRO TALKING
ABOUT CRIME?
WHAT IS WRONG WITH THESE PEOPLE?
>> Harold: I'M GLAD THAT
EVERYTHING IS WELL WITH YOUR
HAND.
I WAS WORRIED ABOUT YESTERDAY.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU ARE
WORRIED?
THANKS FOR THE EMAIL.
>> Harold: I SENT YOU A TEXT.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS.
DANA KNOWS THIS, AND HAS
PRACTICED THIS.
I WAS ON THE BALLOT AT THE END
OF THE CAMPAIGN AND WHEN THINGS
ARE NOT GOING YOUR WAY OR THEY
ARE GOING YOUR WAY AND YOU TRY
TO OUTLINE THINGS THAT ARE GOING
YOUR WAY OR TRY TO DEFLATE OR
DISMISS OR BELITTLE THE THINGS
THAT ARE NOT.
SOME THINGS ARE STRAINING THE
NOTION OF ACCURACY.
FRIENDS AND MY PARTY ARE SAYING
THINGS THAT MAY NOT NECESSARILY
ALTOGETHER BE TRUE.
AGAIN, THERE'S A LONG TRADITION
OF THAT IN AMERICA.
I THINK OF THE END OF A
CAMPAIGN, I THINK THE THING
THAT'S MOST REFRESHING IS IT
APPEARS THAT THE LINES OF BEEN
DRAWN IN A CAMPAIGN.
DEMOCRATS CARE DEEPLY ABOUT
FREEDOM OF CHOICE.
AFFORDABILITY AND DRUG PRICES
AND DEMOCRATS CARE DEEPLY ABOUT
SUPPORTING UKRAINE.
SOME OF THE REPUBLICAN FRIENDS,
OLD CALLINGS OF MINE, EVEN ONES
I DIDN'T SERVE WITH THAT IF
REPUBLICANS GET THE MAJORITY
THAT UKRAINIANS WILL GET A PENNY
MORE OR A DIME MORE FROM THE
COUNTRY.
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE SAID
REPUBLICANS WOULD NOT PROVIDE
ANOTHER DIME TO UKRAINE.
>> Dana: THAT'S LIKE SAYING
LIKE RICK SCOTT --
>> Harold: YOU CAN'T ASSIGN
AOC TO ME AND YOU CAN'T ASSIGN
SUNNY HOSTIN TO ME.
I DON'T TAKE IT PERSONALLY, HIS
POLITICS.
YOU CAN'T GET OFFENDED WHEN
DEMOCRATS ARE FIRING BACK AS
WELL.
THIS IS REAL-TIME HIGH-STAKES
POLITICS.
DEMOCRATS BELIEVE THAT IF
REPUBLICANS THINK THE MAJORITY
THINGS ARE GOING TO CHANGE WILL
BE A LOT OF INVESTIGATIONS.
I THINK HILLARY CLINTON IS RIGHT
IN ONE REGARD.
I'M NOT HEARD REPUBLICANS SAY
WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO DO.
IF YOU BELIEVE WE SHOULD NOT
FUND UKRAINE THEN YOU ARE SAYING
YOU WANT GAS PRICES TO BE HIGHER
BECAUSE THAT MEANS THAT PUTIN IS
IN A STRONGER POSITION.
>> Dana: YOU NEED TO READ THE
COMMITMENT TO AMERICA.
>> Harold: THERE'S A
SCOTT AND McCARTHY.
AT SOME POINT, ALL THESE ISSUES
SHOULD BE ON THE TABLE.
>> Judge Jeanine: LET'S TALK
ABOUT REALITY.
REALITY IS HILLARY CLINTON
SAYING CRIME IS SOMETHING CRAZY.
>> Harold: SHE'S WRONG.
I WOULD AGREE.
WHAT ABOUT UKRAINE?
>> Bill: I WANTED THANK HAROLD
FOR HAVING ME HERE.
AND I'D LIKE TO MAKE A MOTION,
JUDGE.
MY MOTION IS, RAISE YOUR RIGHT
HAND.
>> Harold: I WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE THIS ELECTION IS MADE.
WE ARE READY TO GO.
WITH REGARD TO THE SPIN I WOULD
SAY WATCH THE MARGIN OF THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS ON TUESDAY.
THAT'S EITHER GOING TO CRUSH THE
SPIN OR IT'S GOING TO HELP IT
LIVE FOR ANOTHER DAY.
WITH REGARD TO COCKROACHES, THEY
REALLY LIKED THEM IN 2020.
NOT SO MUCH NOW BASED ON THE WE
ARE HEARING FROM EARLY VOTING IN
THE WAY WOMEN HAVE MOVED AWAY
FROM DEMOCRATS TOWARDS
REPUBLICANS.
I VOTED YESTERDAY IN NEW YORK.
NEW YORK IS THE MOST
EXTRAORDINARY VOTING EXPERIENCE
YOU'LL EVER HAVE.
YOU GO IN THE BOOTH, AM I WRONG
ABOUT THIS?
THE STATE SUPREME COURT JUSTICES
ARE ALL THESE.
THERE'S NOT A REPUBLICAN ON THE
BALLOT.
FOUR INITIATIVES.
THE FIRST ONE IS TO SPEND AN
ADDITIONAL $400 BILLION.
400 BILLION ON CLIMATE CHANGE.
IN NEW YORK STATE.
PROPOSITION -- BUT A FEW OTHERS.
THERE IS A RACIAL EQUITY
COMMISSION.
THEY WANT TO PUT IN THE CITY
CHARTER AND A TRUE
COST-OF-LIVING PROVISION.
THE PRESIDENT SAID THE ECONOMY
WAS IN RUINS WHEN HE CAME INTO
OFFICE.
AND THERE WAS NO PLAN FOR THE
PANDEMIC.
THE PLAN WAS THE VACCI